hey everybody as mentioned I'm hunter
and I'm here from the government here to
help hopefully so today's talk is going
to be about how we use Python in the
city of Los Angeles kind of giving an
overview and then a particular case
study involving mobility data including
using some machine vision stuff that
we've been doing and also some data
specification stuff with the scooters
getting the case studies but just give
you a little sense of mice totally
transparent secret motive for this talk
is we are gonna have to hire about 500
to a thousand technical roles in the
city of Los Angeles in the next three to
five years due to retirement and every
government is pretty much going through
the same thing where we like need to
like hire a ton of people who understand
how to use technology so I want you to
consider a career in public service this
is my totally transparent motive so I
always find it helpful to give you a
little sense of like Who am I and how
did I get here
so I before I worked for the city
I worked for the Center for data science
and public policy and the data science
for social good fellowship the
University of Chicago and I'm super
active in our local my old local civic
hacking group which is Shaq Knight and
if you're in LA hack for LA they're both
affiliated part of the Code for America
brigades program so if you want to get
involved in like civic technology and
civic hacking and you were like I don't
necessarily know if I want to work full
time for the government please I
encourage you to check out hack for LA
or if you go to Code for America you can
actually see of whichever one is local
to your jurisdiction but hacker LA has
tech nights on the west side and he said
working on civic technology programs
helped make la a better place so this is
Los Angeles you probably knew that this
is what you might not know
so we've about four million residents in
the city of LA we service about 65,000
miles of streets LA has the largest
street network of any city in the United
States this is a continual source of
like hassle and trouble for us you may
have heard of this thing called traffic
that our constituents don't love we're
trying to fix it it's hard we receive
about 700,000 service requests a year
who have you filed a through on one
service request all right something I'm
gonna pick on one of you what did you
file a 3-1 request for
dead tree yeah so we will clean up dead
trees when you file through one one
request for bulky item pickup so that's
our biggest driver we will pick up a
bulky item anywhere in the city of Los
Angeles within 48 hours and we do that
regularly so like this is a huge
operation there are hundreds of people
who work on this and like making sure
that goes out on time there are
technical roles they're huge they're
like physically you actually pick it up
there's disposal there's environmental
concerns they're sooo you know we can
talk about our sewer network like the
city is huge so how do you like start to
think about measuring it so the way we
split in like our internal data group
how we think about the city is are we
talking about a policy or are we talking
about an operation so as I mentioned
through in one service request that's an
example of an operation like we
physically go out and do things
constantly seven hundred thousand-plus
times a year so an operate a policy is
something where we're actually making
something you might know as the law or
what I like to call government code the
LA Municipal Code so we joke our job is
to turn computer code into government
code so stuff might be like a traffic
demand management policy like there's
all these sort of levers where the
government has a huge amount of
influence on how the built environment
has been built in the world you live in
and like we often have no data when
we're like starting this process so it's
like how do we actually use data to make
sure that like our traffic demand
policies aren't just a thing that we
have that exists but are a thing that we
have that exists that is helping reduce
traffic in the city of LA so like you
might have you know an operation like
Port Todd runtimes we've poured emission
standards the city is really an A to Z
shop we have everything from the airport
to the zoo so this big question like
linking our policy and operations to
outcomes because the idea here is like
let's do government in a way that like
makes sense and I promise this is going
to get technical very quickly but I
wanted to give you like a high-level
overview of like why is it important to
do good programming and good data
science in government so like rigorous
measurement in testing this sounds like
this is fairly radical when it comes to
like
government in the idea of like hey we
can actually measure and test whether a
policy is working and we can do it a lot
quicker than we used to be able to so
let's give some examples of that because
that was like kind of this very
theoretical thing so nobody likes paying
taxes but it's the law and we have a
team of about 45 people in the city who
audit businesses so the thing is is they
can only audit about 0.5% of the
businesses in Los Angeles we have every
year so we worked with them to build a
predictive model of which businesses we
should audit this role resulted in a
quadrupling of the successful audit rate
so instead of every one in ten
businesses that we audited actually
resulting in us finding somebody who was
cheating on their taxes we're now at
about 50% so that's been a huge you know
internal win for us this means like hey
your tax dollars are being better spent
businesses that are you know don't need
to be audited or not getting audited in
businesses that have been likely to you
know have previously not paid their
taxes are now being audited who has
heard of the Ellis Act anybody who's
there we go who is who lives in an
apartment in Los Angeles who lives in a
rent-controlled apartment in Los Angeles
so for those of you who live in rent
controlled apartment that's a huge
percentage of our city's residents I
think it's about 30% of the city lives
in rent-controlled apartments these are
apartments that are built before 75s
however there is a state law called the
Ellis Act that allows a landlord to
evict everybody in their apartment and
then convert it into condos however
there's a whole bunch of terms and
conditions associated with the Ellis act
like there's all sorts of fees
associated with it there's rent you have
to pay rent for any talents you might
want to Ellis Activision's so
unscrupulous landlords have a habit of
telling their court their tenants I'm
Ellis acting this building you have to
move and they don't actually tell us
you're the government that they have to
file this Ellis Act that with which
means that the tenants don't get the
benefits that they're entitled to under
the law in a building that
it's active so we have a outreach team
about a hundred people who work in our
housing and community investment
department speak I think that team
speaks no fewer than seven different
languages and they need to know which
buildings and which neighborhoods should
I be going to where there's likely to be
an Ellis Act so again you know they
don't have enough resources to go to
every building in Los Angeles every year
there's about 250 of these a years so we
were able to use scikit-learn pandas
pretty basic machine learning tools to
predict which buildings are likely to be
Ellis active and then we hand that list
over to our outreach teams who are able
to go to the buildings and provide
information about like what you're
entitled to as a renter and that's has
resulted in that we are actually out in
front of this problem so instead of
people already being victim over eCourse
they actually know who to call when an
Ellis act is being filed so that they
can get access to the proper resources
we worked again in housing how many
databases do people think the city of
Los Angeles has individual Segal
databases any guesses 10,000 okay
anybody else all right so we have about
2000 databases it's a little smaller
than that but still in that order of
magnitude
so somewhat obviously some of these
databases are describing the same thing
one of the biggest areas where we face a
problem is we have like about 15
different databases that slowly describe
which type of affordable housing is
available in different parcels so we
were able to use pandas and the I highly
recommend dee doop library to dee doop
all these databases and allow you to see
an individual picture of you know this
is 1700 West Magnolia Boulevard and you
can see how many RSO units are how many
like you don't have to know what these
acronyms are but like this is this used
to take somebody 45 minutes to do one
building and now they can do it in about
three seconds just using like very
simple open-source tools another big
project we're working on is earthquake
early warning so this is in partnership
with the United States Geological Survey
and Caltech if you live in California
you are probably rightfully are is
everybody prepared for an earthquake
everybody has a kit please nod and
please go make a kit like in all
seriousness like get prepared for an
earthquake there's all sorts of great
resources available online and linked in
this talk but one of the things that's
been super important for us is we've
been investing a bunch of money along
with the state of California and the
federal government in what's called an
earthquake early warning system so these
systems will give you 30 seconds to 2
minutes heads up of strong shaking
likely to occur it involves a predictive
model that basically as the ground
starts rumbling as you can see out here
on the San Andreas Fault the S wave and
P wave take longer to travel like it's
only traveling at the speed of sound
through rock so we can actually get a
short warning you know depending on how
many sensors there are anywhere between
30 seconds and 2 minutes of what is like
if they're shaking the inker and you're
like all right hunter what can I do with
30 seconds to two minutes so there are a
lot of important things for people to do
obviously you can get prepared like if
you're you know in a you know building
you can go drop cover and hold on you
know all the sorts of things but what's
also important is that we prepare our
machinery using to handle an earthquake
so one of the things we're working on
doing is automatically raising fire
doors so it turns out if you shake a
fire station really hard for 30 seconds
the rails that the door physically lifts
on might slide off this means that the
fire truck that is responsible for
responding to emergencies the second
after an earthquake says might be stuck
inside the building so if we can raise
those fire doors automatically before
the earthquake hits it's a huge win to
make sure our public safety response
times go up this is one thing we're
working on there's gonna be an innovate
la event focused on all the different
earthquake early warning pilots going on
in the city coming up next week so
search that online some things to be
aware of when you start working with
government data so people often talk
about biasing machine learning right
there's a talk about model fairness the
bias is never coming from the machine
learning in my line of work it is always
coming from inside of your data the way
we collect data is in
apparently bias the processes in which
data is collected encode a form of bias
any data scientists worth their salt
especially those of you who work on
problems that are important to our
public you know as a civic institution
need to understand that your data is
inherently biased and you need to
understand what you can and cannot use
that data for these are this trade offs
another thing that I believe very
strongly about how government should do
is your algorithms need to be
interpreted you can't have any black
boxes you know it's okay that I don't
know how Amazon predicts which I bought
a trash game it wants me to buy six more
trash cans it's a private company but
when you're working in the public trust
and the public space you can't have
these black boxes um working in the
public sphere means working in the
public interest and this is like I think
really important for those of you who
like working fields that are adjacent
maybe your firm does government
contracting maybe your firm is doing
something that serves a huge number of
people like in health care you know also
sort of like we working in the public
interests you know the public sphere
means you should work in the public
interests this is the thing I just feel
strongly about this and then another way
is like going back to my slide you know
the policy when we make a policy
wouldn't make a law that becomes
essentially an algorithm for the way we
build our cities our community our state
our country the algorithm becomes the
operation you know we have these three
one one folks who pick up bulky items
all the time but if you live in you know
different cities they will not pick up
bulky items as frequently so your
operations are different and then your
operations is fundamentally impact on
people's lives so this is that's like
sort of the theory of like Python and
data you know at a government scale like
what's important to us I'm gonna dive
down really low and focus on
transportation and mobility for a little
bit so we have two little case studies
here machine vision there's a typo there
for pedestrian and bike counting so this
is our first case study so what you've
got here is a map of ways traffic jams
at 2:00 p.m. on a Friday afternoon
from our ways connected cities
partnership feed the city has a ton of
information about how people use
automobiles to get around the city of
Los Angeles and all that information
comes to us in an incredibly high
fidelity whether it's the Waze traffic
jams we need our auto at SAC system
which is a bunch of camera we have about
600 cameras around the city that help us
monitor traffic conditions we have
what's called RIT's this is actually a
regional system if you've ever looked
inside a street have you ever seen a
little black circle that kind of looks
like a darker outline on asphalt these
are magnetic sensors that how count how
many cars are going through your
highways and your major arterial roads
constantly like Internet of Things it
was built for the 84 Olympics it's an
incredibly complex system kind of
amazing that this thing exists so but
we're getting data that's like 24 hours
a day seven days a week so compare that
to how we measure bicyclists and
pedestrians this is a spreadsheet that
is the result of somebody sitting at a
corner and Counting how many bicyclists
and how many pedestrians went walked by
so you know there's this manual process
yet when we go to talk about these
projects we compare these two datasets
and like any analysts should be able to
say hey that's maybe not a great idea if
we have data with this incredibly high
fidelity 24 hours a day seven days a
week we're gonna have much more granular
data than this like one person sat on a
corner for one day that could be
influenced by all sorts of things what
was the weather that day were there any
special events etc etc so if you are a
if you're Santa Monica what'd you do to
fix this problem is you actually buy
pedestrian and bike counters these are
physical things you can see that Santa
Monica has about 35 miles of major
arterial road I have about 3000 so it's
cost prohibitive for the city of LA to
do what Santa Monica did but we do have
is we have all these cameras on almost
all of our major arterial roads so you
know we were like alright let's think
about
you know how can we use machine visions
a thing like we can probably detect that
so we're like Google I've got some
really good machine vision technology
let's go see how good they are at using
our outside cameras to detect if there's
a pedestrian in that image Google has an
incredible algorithm this is like
off-the-shelf like pre built AI for you
it's very good at telling me I'm looking
at a road it's very good it's got this
is a mode of transport
it's a lane it's some infrastructure I
really love 68% probability that you're
looking at some infrastructure what's
that mean
that's like anyways so because this
algorithm was previously of a purpose of
general purpose image classification it
wasn't actually very good at the thing
we want it to do which was people and
bike recognition so working with Cal
State University Los Angeles's data
science research lab they are awesome
they built a customized algorithm that
we still deploy on aw still on the cloud
british-trained just specifically to
recognize pedestrians and cyclists and
furthermore it's not trained to
recognize faces at all it is just
recognizing the counts all we get from
this system is there's one person this
is a down in Little Tokyo it's first in
Alameda you know two people walking by I
don't know if that person then went to
the I don't want to know if that person
then showed up in another camera over
there that's like a violation of civil
liberties we don't want to cause that it
uses our existing infrastructure so even
when you've got you know really janky
old technology these are like 1990s
grade analog cameras we have a analog
digital converter inside the central
control room that we use to pipe this
stuff to the cloud
these cameras shake because when
somebody drives a truck by one of these
poles it starts shaking the camera so
there's all these sort of issues you
have to deal with to get at these counts
but that's incredibly powerful because
now I can say going across the first
Admission Street bridge and it's not
really me who's saying this but other
you know folks from our Department of
Transportation and our policy makers can
now say okay we had this many bikes this
many pedestrians this many people in
buses and this many people driving and
that way we can actually like tie any of
these policies when we change the road
infrastructure to what actually changed
the mode
sher infrastructure so you know people
say like counting is easy right counting
is hard this is like two years worth of
work I'm just getting better at counting
so that's first case study I'm gonna
like paw Paw's really quickly I'm gonna
push QA towards the end and just kind of
filled all these questions rapid-fire
but who view is seen like a scooter or
shared Dhokla see bike in their time in
LA who views written one hands can stay
up do you like riding them no got some
nose you get some yeses if you who you
are not from so the folks who are not
from LA we've seen a proliferation of
these companies there's now four or five
companies providing Dhokla scooters andy
bikes around sort of a disruption in the
what we call the mobility marketplace so
to frame this la is experiencing a
disruption across the mobility market
and this is not just the scooters you
may remember when this happened this was
kind of like eye opening to local
governments which is like company is
just cab markets as like a marketplace
had been very static and now this is
streets in which coober driver is you
know an uber keep map from spring 2016
so we've launched an Eevee car sharing
program in low-income neighborhoods we
now have all these scooters and bikes
half of these companies have left the US
market you know we have people talking
about building tunnels so how do we
manage this process so you know
especially with sort of an eye on the
future of like look we're gonna have
autonomous vehicles people say we're
gonna have drones and this is like this
is the thorny technical problem how do
you support a city with hundreds of
thousands of different shared autonomous
devices in hundreds of different cities
with a near infinite supply of education
does anybody know how many cities there
are in LA County alone there are 88
cities in LA County plus unincorporated
County
so just in LA County there
89 sets of different traffic laws now a
lot of that is standardized right like
no matter which city you're driving in a
red light means a red light a stop sign
means a stop sign in lane markings mean
lane markings you know but so what we've
been thinking about is what's the
digital version of that so we went this
is like fairly radical for government
but we went on and we made something we
call the mobility data specification so
the mobility data specification is a set
of api's that allow us to manage and
control mobility devices autonomous
mobility devices starting specifically
with scooters and oculus bike-share you
see we've had contributions city of
Santa Monica we've had the city of San
Francisco Seattle Austin and the
companies themselves have been
contributing to the specification
it is completely open-source we're using
semantic versioning we've got about
we've just appointed there was a point
to version or Willow I ago but what we
give is a set of API is that allow you
to do a stop sign but digitally and
understand trips digitally so any
company that operates in the city of Los
Angeles is part of getting their full
conditional use and full permit for a
permanent process or you don't need to
care about has to build what we call the
provider API additionally in the city of
La we're building something called the
agency API so the way to think about
this is the provider API looks backwards
lets us describe operations about what's
been going on with these companies
agency API looks forward about handling
things like license and registration
handling things such as you know
permitting updating Clemmie tree warning
users if you're about to go into
construction zone all of that
functionality can be exposed again what
we're not trying to do is launch our own
app that like competes with these
mobility providers like we want them to
do what they do best
what we want to do is support having the
data available to us so you can see you
know - regardless of which city you're
in it doesn't matter if it's Santa
Monica or LA you know it's it looks
seamless to the end-user so the data
that we get we have this
instead of asking traditionally when
governments do permitting programs like
this like we would permit taxicabs we
permit anything
we'll ask like tell me what percentage
the data that we asked for generally is
like on a quarterly basis please give me
a floppy disk full of what percentage of
your customers were low income this is
like the wrong way to do this thing the
way to do this so it actually works in
real time is like think about what are
the atomic and small data models you
need to create for these devices so we
do basically two one is a status change
this is a representing of something
reserving or not reserving the curb and
then we have trips this is fairly spell
some explanatory one important thing
about this is there is no personally
identifiable information in this data
set we don't ask for like which user is
making the trip we just want to know did
you put a scooter on that curb so that
we can make sure that it's not in the
handicapped zone so there's a huge you
know now like six or seven different
open-source repos aside from some
companies offering this available to you
we have a bunch of open-source projects
available to help load this we have our
air flow based in gestation to love the
city of la Santa Monica is building
their own separate tools but essentially
we have a provider API we pull that data
into AWS and then we use that for
reporting functions or monitoring
compliance functions so for example in
the city of La we advise that you don't
leave a scooter on the corner for more
than 24 hours so as part of this as this
is being set up
every time a scooter has been hits
existing on a curb for 24 hours we send
an automated email to that company if we
receive one of those 301 service
requests to remove it we then route that
to the proper company all sorts of
really interesting like hard matching
and data problems going on in the back
end there we also do a lot of really
interesting validation of this using
JSON schema so going back to this like
okay you have hundreds of cities dozens
of companies like you can't validate
this by hand like you can't have well
company a describes a trip like this
and Company B describes a trip like this
so we use JSON schema to automate our
validation and then we have an agency
API which is what the companies use to
access information about us like if they
want to register a new vehicle so that
we can keep them inside their cap
compliance numbers
if they want to you know rent a vehicle
there's different end points available
there you know and there's going to be a
developer portal that they can access so
that's what's coming in the future I'm
gonna skip this section of like how
measuring the Cape's about moving
devices is kind of hard if you want to
ask me about that you know there's some
code online you can take a look at
because I want to get to the point of if
you were interested in all these sort of
problems if you want to help solve the
future mobility if you want to talk
about healthcare there are tons of jobs
available in government and I want you
to consider a career in public service
so here are some local links you know
there's our personnel site LA County
also hiring it on Metro there's work in
the federal government every one of us
needs to hire so really I encourage you
to go out and apply but sort of a
whirlwind tour of how we use Python at
the city of La and I think I'm going to
open it up to QA all right so yeah I'll
be roaming around with the mic if
anybody has any questions
hi what's been the biggest adjustment
for you working within a city government
I think the biggest adjustment is
adjusting your time scale if you come
from a you know private environment you
know there's typically the number of
people you need to buy off the
expectation of how quickly things should
exist city government doesn't stop
existing no government stops existing
the city of LA has been around for
longer than this country has some of the
data sources that I work with daily like
our parcels data file you know have
relics of the Spanish land grant program
that started when you know this was part
of the Spanish this area was part of the
Spanish Empire and like so the way you
plan things is like pretty much in a
yearly cycle so working from like where
things might have been planned in a
quarterly or sprint cycle and you can
bring those into the way you actually
build your stuff but in terms of your
long term planning that time Verizon has
just completely blown open to me you
guys plan for the Olympics and if you
are how's that headache going um we are
there's a whole like office of Olympic
at like folks who are hired like just to
start getting prepared for the Olympics
as well I'm not particularly involved
with that project I suspect as it gets
closer they will start to ask more
questions around data and stuff and then
tends to me when I show up how come we
can't get a train to the airport
we are it's being built like you can go
see the construction site right now um
again like government is a participatory
process and you know I think now we're
getting to the point where there's you
know enough will to build a train to the
airport but there was not necessarily
you know 45 years ago there was not
necessarily the will to do that and then
honestly it just takes time you know
there's a lot of trade-offs involved in
constructing something in someplace like
you could build a train to the airport a
lot quicker if you said we're just gonna
demolish LAX and then build a train and
then rebuild the airport and it's gonna
be closed for two years but I think
every one of you would say off with his
head like immediately after that so you
know the challenges of you know we're
building the bicycle we're building the
Train we're built well we're riding it
constantly because the city as I said it
doesn't stop so that's one of the
reasons some things take longer than
they might in you know a certain
disrupter say well if I just start
digging a tunnel you know you might also
hit a you know gas pipeline and you know
blow up a large city block which is you
know there's a reason we do this stuff
slowly because we need to do it right
it's a really intriguing policy decision
to essentially force companies to
interact with an API to provide service
to their customers which are members of
the community that that paradigm is
incredibly interesting - do you have any
precedent or what led you to propose
that as a solution is a very program ik
and mandated API interaction between
private company and public interest
right so the legal justification that
like our attorneys can tell you is like
they are putting stuff in the public
right-of-way and it is our legal
responsibility to manage the public
right-of-way as California Vehicle Code
and government code I cannot say the
numbers for you but that's what the
attorneys will say why we decided doing
an API instead of the traditional method
is like we can't scale these use
like and I get an annual report about
the scooters and I'm like if people are
complaining about you know there's one
in the Venice canal they don't want to
know in our annual report oh we only saw
3% of scooters you know had problems
they want us to say okay we're working
on it we're gonna issue a ticket it will
be gone within 48 hours and the way we
do that is via an API or sets of API is
really hunter up how I'm curious how
routed do you think the type of data
science you're bringing to the city is
in like the institution like say if
later today you were hit by a bus or I
must factor or even worse for you I'm
sure one of elon self-driving cars oh if
you were hit by one and you were gone
would with the the work you're doing at
the city survive is it is it is it
integrated into the institution's yet or
is it still kind of grafted on top is it
perfect no are we getting there
yes so right now there is a dedicated
city budget line item for a citywide
data science and predictive analytics
team we are growing when I started it
was grafted on like I was one person
we're now going to be four by the end of
this fiscal year will hopefully be more
of a year after that and if you know
something about city budget line items
they don't tend to go away so I'm really
hopeful that you know it takes time to
do this but I'm pretty optimistic that
we're gonna have really rooted a strong
analysis culture in the city so I used
to work for Freddie Mac which is like a
large orange and like oh I know all of
these problems these are the transparent
model stuff and all that kind of thing
and I always found the problems like I'd
go into room be like hey we should have
an API for this and just like no one
understood what I was talking about so
even like in a financial firm which was
technically literate they were
incredibly technically illiterate and
I'm just wondering sort of like how do
you approach the the whole framework in
a community that is not necessarily
yeah so it's ad eyes are good and why do
we all think ap eyes are good
we all think AP eyes are good because it
enables us to do all these interesting
sort of things on top of it like I can
access the data quicker therefore I can
build these models quicker and therefore
like Freddie Mac is more stable more
profitable more able to achieve its end
goals so notice the reason like I exist
is like because there are like senior
leadership in the city who believes our
policy and operations can be better
informed with data so I don't say like
hey we need an API I say hey the overall
goal of this project is fix our street
sweeping routes is you know identify who
is at risk of you know becoming being
evicted like and then like I'm like okay
in order to do this well we need an API
like this is the thing we now need to do
the thing you want then eight sort of
solve is that chicken and an egg problem
I don't know if it's a perfect answer
and it fails a lot but it works some of
the time so that's good enough for me
hi I'm sure you have hundreds of data
problems only one of you how do you
prioritize which is the most pressing
need there's this thing called the city
council and the mayor and they tend to
very quickly tell you what the major
problems in the city are and they have
this thing called a budget letter and
it's like a very internal document where
they tell you what the priorities are
for the year and then they also make
laws so yeah we have leadership they
it's not to say it's not my problem but
it is decided to level above my head
thanks for this talk this is pretty
awesome
so I'm from Seattle and there's a
Seattle open data portal where we can
explore as you know citizens of Seattle
like are available do you have an
equivalent thing yes not actually so
there's another City team that manages
open data so we have both data I linked
to on the bottom of slide and I was kind
of ramming through the stock real quick
so he could get to Q&A but yeah so dated
LA City and geo hubs LA City for all
your geographic and open data needs and
again open data also gets actually the
biggest users of open data sites tend to
be internal users cuz oh I can now get
data that describes things I'm doing but
wasn't in my department actually tends
to be
huge thing so I use those sites daily I
was interested by the requirement of
interpretable models as it relates to
the business tax fraud detection like is
that model kept confidential or
something it seemed so the data is
obviously kept confidential because I'm
not gonna go put your data but we do the
model is available online so if you had
simulated fake data that is of similar
distributions you could see how we
arrived at this model but like you can
follow again it's just pandas
scikit-learn and a random forest it's
not the most revolutionary it is really
not revolutionary technologies but you
can still do a lot of good with not you
don't have to like deep learn or
blockchain your way to social good you
can like clean up some data and like
figure out how to make somebody's life
like 80% easier and solve a lot of
problems so many of your problems I'm
sure problems that every city or many
cities in America are trying to solve
have you to what extent you've worked
with other cities to try to collaborate
and figure out what have they solved
already yeah so that's like this huge if
any like broader like Civic Technology
Public Interest technology government
data or whatever this community that
like we're kind of a part of is called
is kind of this huge thing that we've
had trouble solving I think with the
mobility data specification because it
was a new area we were able to work
really closely with a lot of other
cities cuz like we're not the only ones
facing an onslaught of scooter and bikes
and like those who are also trying to
like manage it and grow it and not just
saying like there are a lot of cities
that just said no or okay if you're New
York like New York's policies on around
scooters and bikes is okay you can put
200 of them in the Rockaways and that's
it so like when you're actually trying
to like manage these things like the
cities that have been trying to do that
have been we've been in sort of this
participating process with github and
open source there are also networks of
folks so there's like the chief data
officer network so our city's chief de
officer participates in that and she
brings back a lot of technologies from
other cities and best practices there's
all sorts of like there are entire
conferences solely dedicated to
government technology if you really you
know want to walk it out but I still
think it's kind of an unsolved problem
of like the other problem that kind of
is like every city is just a little bit
different which means their data
collection process is just a little bit
different and this was one of the key
things we realize but the SCOOTER data
was like we have an opportunity because
it's a new area to make everything at
least look the same even if all of our
policy goals are different the data is
the same but if you're talking about
every city's financial tax collection
systems I had some both there are a lot
of Oracle databases all with different
schemas if there are folks in the room
or have friends who are interested in
getting jobs as public servants do you
have a high level any like warnings or
advice for them and navigating the
process where to go for help on that
because I hear it's quite different than
industry hiring mm-hm yeah so getting
hired in government takes time so the
trade-off to this is like you get a
pension and you get like pretty much a
career track and it will like there are
50,000 people who work in the city of La
there are a hundred thousand who work at
the county like you keep promoting like
inside this system because it is a small
city worth of people who work for the
government just in our County alone you
know I'm sure plenty of us grew up in
places that are less than 150,000 people
so it takes time to break in but once
you're in you can work it's like work
your way up loading so that's the way
the system is currently designed I don't
really have any comments on like is this
good or bad but fundamentally like throw
in your application as soon as possible
and just prepare to like don't have to
do anything wait around then you have to
do a lot of things one week and then you
just wait around a long time again for
at least like full-time civil service
jobs that being said there are a huge
array of like government adjacent and
civil service adjacent stuff whether
that's being hired into an elected
office or being hired at a university to
do research on civic data or being hired
at a company like Fair and peers that
does a ton of consulting for the
government that hire on like a more
schedule if you are actually looking to
change your job right now and it's very
typical for people to sort of take that
as an intermediary step to like a full
civil service career it is how I got
started I was in a research lab then I
was contracting now I'm full-time civil
service I know you mentioned like hack
for LA how easy is it for like a person
that wants to contribute
I'm software engineer not a data
scientist but to contribute to like a
project that's actually being worked on
rather than just some hack for lays like
oh this is a cool project that someone
maybe not as experienced it might be
interested in like just getting their
hands wet and versus someone that's
really just like I just want to help the
city it's like how how do how does the
city involve those people or do they
again it's sort of a mixed bag I think
there's a lot of trying but there's also
you know volunteer efforts are not
people who are working on full time
there is a need like in Frisco there's a
lot of really great sort of more
activism II projects that are going on
in hack for LA and that's sort of where
their strong suit is and like where your
strong suit is like a software engineer
might be is like you can do a lot just
be to like a Shia hack night example you
know one of those sites that I remember
being built at cha hack night was my
building doesn't recycle calm and so the
city of Chicago had like this long
problem with like different apartment
owners they're supposed to recycle they
didn't recycle it was hard to report it
like this site made it abundantly clear
resulted in a change in the policy that
then resulted in a change in the
operation in a way your registration of
businesses that are landlords needs to
go in the city I got to ensure recycling
so this like over the course of a year
like an activist II website changed the
City Council's policy which then changed
like the operating departments like
actual people who like our IT people or
website people to change their website
to make sure that the policy reflects
the the operation reflects the policy so
that's sort of where I think the strong
suit for like civic technology groups
are especially volunteer loved ones and
I actually has a ton of projects like
that that you can get involved with any
Monday night on the west side and
Tuesday nights downtown check out their
website
how hard is it to like shift your
priorities when city council or mayor
changes I haven't lived through change
yet so in terms of my operation you know
I don't know yet in terms of like
overall City you know again a lot of the
times so much of our responsibilities
are pretty you know it doesn't matter
who's the mayor who's the council like
you still want your garbage picked up
you still want your you know 300 cross
fields people still need like the
traffic signals need to go on every day
so you know the leadership definitely
changes but the bulk of city operations
are pretty static I think we've got time
for one or two more questions if
anyone's so real quick I wanted to tie
up with a previous one about hack for LA
there's a number of these groups in
different cities San Diego's got one San
Mateo's got one if your city doesn't
feel free to start one at scale will
actually have a booth for those
communities and we're actually looking
to do track at scale so talk to me if
you'd like to participate in helping to
make it track for like a day at scale
and work with a hack for LA guys Thanks
I'm starting a dangerous scooter gang
called the Sons of auxilary power and
we're gonna collect up all of the
scooters and charge them for the money
that the companies pay can I publicly
hit your API hundred thousand times a
second um so the answer is these are the
API I don't as there was a architecture
diagram slide that I have lost eyes my
laptop's out of battery
but essentially is the API is that we're
working with solely govern the
relationship between the companies like
bird and lime and uber and lyft and the
city they are they are authenticated
each way this is not a publicly that if
you want to talk about like GB FS and
like the publicly available stuff that's
a different universe and that's governed
by NASA which is the National
Association of bike share something
North American bike sharing Association
there we go but so we don't we don't
really touch that because again this is
about what our tools need to be to
manage the public right-of-way and not
necessarily like getting involved in the
company's operations I'll be here for
another few minutes and then I'm like
easily findable on the internet if you
have any questions and like on a last
note if you if you find this interesting
if this is eye-opening like poker on the
internet and highly get involved
government is what you make of it
[Applause]